Bem, durante décadas você deve ter
escutado que banco era veneno puro. Eu
escutava de uma pessoa que trabalhava lá
em casa quando eu era adolescente.
Depois virou a queridinha das dietas
ancestrais e lowcarb. Mas afinal de
contas, essa gordura tradicional que a
sua avó usava na cozinha em curta vida
ou pode fazer parte de uma alimentação
saudável? Olha só esse dado. Um estudo
publicado em dezembro de 25 na revista
NPJ Science of Food mostrou algo que vai
contra tudo o que você já ouviu.
Pesquisadores compararam o consumo
moderado de banho de porco, óleo de
camélia e óleo de amuim e descobriram
que o grupo que consumiu banha teve
menor menor acúmodo de gordura corporal
e menor inflamação no tecido adiposo.
Isso mesmo. você não ouviu errado. Eu
sei que parece contrainttuitivo, afinal
você escutou isso tantos anos, né? Mas a
ciência está revisando muitas certezas
antigas sobre gorduras. E hoje eu vou te
mostrar exatamente o que que os estudos
mais recentes dizem. Qual é a composição
real da banha? Onde ela ganha e onde ela
perde? Em que contexto ela pode ou não
fazer parte da sua alimentação? Então
fica comigo até o final porque eu vou te
dar uma orientação prática, equilibrada
sobre esse tema polêmico.
Primeiro, vamos entender uma coisa
fundamental. A composição da banha de
porco é muito diferente do que a maioria
das pessoas imaginam. A gordura de porco
não é majoritariamente saturada. Calma,
já explico. A banha contém
aproximadamente 45% de gordura
monoaturada,
sendo principal componente o famoso
ácido oleico. Sabe onde mais você
encontra esse bendito ácido oleico em
abundância? Acertou no azeite de oliva,
aquele mesmo que todo mundo considera
super saudável. A banha tem mais ácido
leíico do que o óleo de gelim, do que,
por exemplo, mais do que o dobro do óleo
de milho e quase três vezes mais que o
óleo de girassol. Cerca de 40 a 45% é
gordura saturada e apenas 10 a 15% é
gordura polinsaturada. E tem mais um
detalhe importante. Quando a banha não é
hidrogenada industrialmente, ela não
contém gordura trans. Zero, zero de
trans. Isso relevante porque muitos
óleos vegetais processados acabam
gerando gordura transfino, o
aquecimento. Agora vem a parte que
confunde muita gente. Se a banha não é
tão ruim assim em termos de composição,
por que diabos ela foi tão demonizada? A
história começa lá nos anos 1950 com um
pesquisador chamado Ansel Kiss. Ele
propôs a chamada hipótese lipítica, que
basicamente dizia que gordura saturada
eleva colesterol e causa doença
cardíaca. Essa hipótese influenciou as
diretrizes alimentares do mundo inteiro
por muitas décadas. O problema é que a
equação de Kiss, como aponto um estudo
publicado na revista Nutrients em 2024,
cometeu um erro grave. Ela colocou no
mesmo saco a gordura saturada natural
dos nos alimentos e a gordura
transindustrial e considerou apenas o
ácido linoleico como gordura
pós-aturada, ignorando o desequilíbrio
entre ômega-6 e ômega-3. Então, uma
revisão sistemática e metanálise
publicada no JMA Journal em abril de 25
analisou nove ensaios clínicos
adomizados com mais de 13.000
participantes. São 13.000 pessoas,
pessoal, e não encontrou diferença
significativa na mortalidade
cardiovascular, na mortalidade geral, no
infarto ou eventos coronarianos entre os
grupos que reduziram gordura saturada e
os grupos controle. Percebe como a
ciência tá evoluindo? As certezas de
ontem não são necessariamente as
verdades de hoje. Mas antes que você
saia daqui achando que pode sair
fritando tudo na banha sem moderação,
deixa te mostrar o outro lado da moeda.
Um estudo prospectivo russo que foi
publicado no European Journal of Public
Health acompanhou mais de 6.000 pessoas
por 11 anos. encontrou uma associação
entre alta disponibilidade de banha no
domicílio, ou seja, na residência, e
maior risco de doença cardiovascular,
com aumento de 31% no risco combinado de
doença cardiovascular e morte.
Curiosamente, a mesma associação não foi
encontrada, por exemplo, com manteiga ou
óleo vegetal. Então, como é que eu
explico essa aparente contradição? A
resposta é o contexto. Na Rússia do
estudo, o consumo de banho estava
associado a um padrão alimentar bem
específico. Eles também consumiam auto
teor carnes processadas, embutidos,
álcool, baixa ingestão de vegetais.
Então era um padrão alimentar. Além
disso, a quantidade consumida era bem
maior do que a do estudo 25, que mostrou
benefício com consumo moderado.
E é aqui que entra um conceito
fundamental na nutrição moderna. Matriz
alimentar. Não é só o nutriente isolado
que importa, é a combinação, é o
alimento inteiro, o padrão dietético
completo. Uma umbrella review publicado
na revista Nutrients em 21 comparou o
efeito de diferentes óleos nos níveis de
colesterol. E o resultado, quando você
substitui óleos ricos em gordura
poliaturada ou monoaturada por banha, o
LDL colesterol some um pouquinho, entre
8 e 10 mg por dcl. Mas calma, porque
aqui entra um detalhe muito importante,
muda completamente a história. Esse
aumento de LDL total não é
necessariamente problemático. Já falei
isso em vídeos anteriores. O que
realmente importa pro risco
cardiovascular não é o número total de
LDL, mas sim o tipo de partícula.
Existem partículas de LDL grandes e
flutuantes que são bem inofensivas e as
partículas pequenas e densas. são as
bandidas que são as que realmente
oxidam, penetram na parede arterial e
causam aterosclerose. Então, a gordura
saturada da banho, ela tende se aumentar
um pouquinho o LDL, mas é principalmente
as partículas grandes, não as pequenas e
densas. Então aquele aumento de 8 a 10
mg dil no exame pode não significar
aumento real de risco. Por outro lado,
quando você substitui óleos de semente
refinados, ricos em ômega-6 por banha,
você reduz a carga inflamatória
associada ao desequilíbrio do ômega-6,
ôga-3. E aqui está o ponto crucial que
ninguém fala. A maioria dos óleos
vegetais que as pessoas usam no dia a
dia, como soja, milho, girassol, tem uma
proporção de ômega 6 para ômega-3 que
pode chegar 20 para um ou até mais. O
ideal seria algo em torno de quatro para
um. Então esse desequilíbrio crônico tá
associado à inflamação sistêmica de
baixo grau, que é o terreno fértil para
praticamente todas as doenças crônicas
modernas. A banha, por ter baixo TO de
gordura polsaturada, ela simplesmente
não contribui para esse problema na
mesma proporção. Então, qual que é a
orientação prática que eu vou dar aqui
para vocês? Primeiro, contexto
individual importa muito. Se você tem
colesterol LDL muito alto, histórico
familiar de doença cardíaca, alguma
condição metabólica específica, epidemia
familiar, por exemplo, consumir banha em
quantidade elevada vai te ferrar.
Provavelmente não é a melhor escolha. O
azeite de oliva virgem continua sendo
uma opção mais segura pra maioria das
pessoas nas situações. Segundo, se você
vai usar a banha, use com moderação
de forma consciente. O estudo de 25, que
mostrou benefício, trabalhou com consumo
moderado, não era comer banho o dia
inteiro. A banha pode ser uma opção
interessante para frituras ocasionais,
porque ela tem ponto de fumaça mais alto
que muitos óleos vegetais e não formam
compostos tóxicos com a mesma
facilidade. Terceiro, a qualidade
importa sim. Banha de porco da criação
intensiva, esses bichos comendo só ração
à base de soja e milho, vai ter um
perfil lipítico diferente da banha de
porco, criado de forma tradicional
natural. Então, se possível, tente obter
uma banha de origem conhecida e que o
animal seja mais bem tratado. Quarto,
olhe pro padrão alimentar completo. Usar
a banha dentro de uma dieta rica em
vegetais, proteína de qualidade, sem
alimentos ultraprocessados e bom
equilíbrio entre ômega-3 e ômega-6 é
completamente diferente de usar a banha,
como foi lá na Rússia, dentro de um
padrão alimentar baseado em botidos,
refrigerantes e farinha refinada.
Resumindo, a banha de porco não é o
veneno que disseram para você por
décadas, nem disseram para mim também
por décadas, mas também não é o elixê da
longevidade que algumas pessoas possam
parecer crer. Então a verdade sempre tá
no meio. Ela é uma gordura tradicional
com composição majoritariamente
monoaturada que pode fazer parte de uma
alimentação equilibrada dependendo do
contexto da quantidade e do padrão
alimentar geral. Então a ciência tá
mostrando pra gente que é o problema
nunca foi a gordura saturada em si, mas
sim a simplificação exagerada que
colocou todos os tipos de gordura no
mesmo pacote
enquanto liberava óleo refinado de
semente e ultraprocessado como se fosse
saudáveis. Aqui no YouTube eu preciso
simplificar, preciso omitir protocolos
mais específicos sobre gorduras e perfil
lipídico. Por exemplo, eu não posso
falar abertamente sobre interpretar
exames de colesterol de forma mais
completa, incluindo partículas de
Llooxidado.
Na comunidade fechada não tem esse
filtro. Compartilho tudo que eu sei,
protocolos exatos da clínica, incluindo
como avalio o perfil lipídico completo e
quando a gordura saturada pode ser
realmente uma boa. Combinações que
funcionam, fornecedores legais,
interpretação avançada de exames, lives
semanais para tirar dúvidas, PDF com 47
protocolos, grupo no WhatsApp com
pessoas maravilhosas, clica em seja
membro. E no nível dois, a cada duas
semanas nós temos imersões de 2 horas de
secando ativos científicos. como os
últimos estudos sobre gorduras e
metabolismo que a maioria dos médicos
ainda não conhece. Nós debatemos
controvérsias bastidores da ciência. Seu
nome aparece nos meus vídeos como
agradecimento e é o círculo interno de
quem quer ir além. Agradecimentos
especiais de coração aos nossos membros
queridos dos estudos avançados da
comunidade fechada do YouTube. Começando
pelos novos membros que entraram
recentemente, Luciano Silva Paurinelli,
Luciano Elias, Lê Trigono, Juliana
Pontes, Carlos Roveri, Odonor Pinheiro,
Cíntia de Assis Oliveira, Jorge Cabral e
Fernando Machado. Sejam muito
bem-vindos. Agradeço também aos membros
que fizeram upgrade para os estudos
avançados. Irma Iana, Antônio Renato,
Adriane, Dr. Ana Paula Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Murtinho, Soucioli, Cristina
Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela Mari
Silva, Elô Terapias, Luís Anselmo, muito
obrigado pela confiança em elevar o
nível de participação. Um abraço
especial aos membros que retornaram à
comunidade, Alex Caldas, Marcelo
Pimentel e Cláudio Leitão. Que bom ter
vocês de volta. Eu quero fazer um
reconhecimento especial aos membros mais
fiéis. Estela Mares com incríveis 56
meses de fidelidade. Dra. Ana Paula com
44 meses de participação, Marcelo
Pimentel com 23 meses e Antônio Renato
com 21 meses de história conosco. A
todos vocês eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado. você fazem a diferença
nessa comunidade.